sans fil tout de suite maintenant on
passe au cas dans son fils
[Musique]
j'ai envoyé un petit whatsapp abouba
donc voilà je vous dis et qui me dit
qu'il est branché on la perd à priori ça
sent plutôt bon les cherry on va passer
à ce qui a fait le buzz aujourd'hui
cette histoire sur dany boon puisque
l'acteur dany boon est accusé d'
optimiser ses revenus dans des paradis
fiscaux
selon le site mediapart dans une enquête
dont publié hier le site d'investigation
assure que l'acteur enchaîne les
résidence fiscale à l'étranger
l' affaire pourrait bien donc ternir
l'image de la star mais mine de rien il
n'y a rien d'illégal là dedans on va
tout vous expliquer regardez c'est une
polémique pour le moins gênante à
laquelle doit faire face depuis quelques
heures le comédien dany boon suite aux
révélations du journal mediapart la star
de bienvenue chez les ch'tis a toujours
revendiqué être fier de payer ses impôts
en france c'est la première fois de ma
vie j'ai une feuille d'impôts à deux
chiffres en millions
o comme ici dans 7 à vous en 2018 ont
ils expliqué avoir congédié son
comptable qui lui proposer des solutions
selon lui mal honnête il me dit voilà tu
vas gagner autant si tu fais une
structure au luxembourg
tu blessés autorisé tu que tu vas éviter
tant d'impôt est évident que les impôts
il déclarait également journal marianne
je paye 50 % d'impôts en france quoi
qu'il arrive et ça me va très bien j'ai
gagné cet argent grâce à mon pays à
l'éducation que j'ai reçue c'est normal
que ça lui reviennent mais d'après les
journalistes tout ne serait pas aussi
simple selon une récente enquête qui
prétend détenir des preuves dany boon
aurait placé une partie de son argent
dans des résidences fiscale à l'étranger
et dans des investissements de fonds
spéculatifs dans des paradis fiscaux et
pratiques qui ne sont pas illégales mais
qui ne semble pas du tout aller dans le
sens de ce que l'acteur faisait passer
comme message en déclarant être fier de
payer ses impôts
des révélations qui ont choqué de
nombreux internautes alors l'évasion
fiscale de dany boon choquer ou pas
choquer
la question est simple l'évasion fiscale
de dany boon choquer ou pas choquer sa
porte là dessus voilà alors oui ou non
vous avez aux petites pancartes choqué
vraiment pas choquer je rappelle qu'il
n'y a rien d'illégal
voilà vous vous n'êtes pas choquer
géraldine maillet non je suis pas choqué
parce que ce n'est pas illégal
il voudrait payer 50% de ses impôts en
france mais il faut se méfier
aujourd'hui il ya une sorte de chasse à
l'argent la chasse au fric alors en plus
c'est fait par mediapart c'est pas
parole d'évangile mediapart
ils veulent peut-être transformer la
france entrant république trotskiste
d'extrême gauche
moi je déteste ça je l'avais 4ème à
médiapart je trouve qu'il faut se méfier
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt des noms parfois
des choses oui mais parvient c'est vrai
parfois ces faux parfois c'est à prendre
avec des pincettes et je trouve que
voilà je trouve que c'est assez c'est
assez révélateur d'une époque un peu
malsaine et moi qui mettrai très mal à
l'aise
alors jean michel maire aussi voudront
pas choqué parce que sans être voilà je
vais pas faire preuve d'hypocrisie si
j'avais aussi beaucoup d'argent je pense
que comme tout le monde j'ai serré avec
mon mon conseil fiscal de voir comment
optimiser comment nous payer le moins
possible d'impôts
ils font payer c'est normal voilà mais
si on peut en payer moins puisque c'est
légal balle franchement tout le monde le
ferait alors raymond le vous vous êtes
choqués moi je suis un peu choqué parce
que c'est dans l'histoire c'est nous on
est con on peut pas partir on est obligé
de payer nos impôts si on peut pas se
casser nos noms restent là et on paye
moi je suis choqué dans la mesure où que
l'argent il sait les gamins ce qui fait
mais la gagner en france c'est comme
florent pagny c'est comme daniel auteuil
c'est comme goldman pourquoi on tape sur
dany boon aujourd'hui tous les ya eu un
classement des 10 français préféré le
jdd des français préféré les uns des
actes les actrices des actrices les
actes des artistes préférés des français
surtout ils sont tous partis ils sont
tous pas ils sont pas là c'est donc moi
je suis un peu choqué j'aimerais qu'ils
en tiraient choisi après le problème
c'est faux qu'on aime nos artistes
peut-être qu'il faut faire des lois pour
qui sans pourtant pas que tout le monde
se barre comme ça et peut-être moins d
imposer pour pas qu'ils se barrent parce
que les autres pays les accueillent à
bras ouverts
donc je suis un peu choqué c'est comme
panis qui fait des décédés qui vont ici
et déjà mais la mairie vont d'ailleurs
il n'ya pas de la ruche à riec et
thématiquement s'il s'avère que c'est
vrai moi je suis profondément choqué
pourquoi parceque il se dit patriote
fiscale
il nous a dit et nous a bassinés en nous
disant qui payait ses impôts en france
là les 50% c'est arrivé quand même très
récemment c'est effectivement des
acteurs préférés des français
on les aime pour ça parce qu'il est
proche du peuple parce que justement il
a ce côté là donc je suis désolé du lieu
de tournage la france est fière d'avoir
été éduqué en france c'est ce qu'il a
dit qu'il a répétée
tu peux été un peu
attendez attendez attendez
s'il vous plaît après on aura gilles
verdez qui m'a l'air heureux qu'est ce
que ça va pas vous si ça va ou contre
quelque chose mathieu que c'est pénible
ça épi 10 % des gens retenaient ce
chiffre 10 % des gens paient 90 % de
l'impôt
il fait partie des 10 % qui donne une
fortune d'impôts à la france ça paraît
cammas est normal que ce garçon malgré
tout qui a réussi qui a mérité tout ce
qu'il a eu donc aujourd'hui plus mec
maximiser optimiser le fait de il y
donne déjà beaucoup d'argent en france
et le fait de siéger teigne rêve apprend
qu'il s'est senti c'est pas mère teresa
il est pas là pour nourrir tout le monde
il a très bien parlé foot c'est ce que
tu sais à quel point je t'aime mathieu
mais la loi dit n'importe quoi pourquoi
parce que sous prétexte qu'ils gagnent
beaucoup d'argent
eh ben il doit pas donner tous ses
impôts en france là franchement excuse
moi mais tu te mets le doigt dans l'oeil
moi franchement ça me paraît fou quand
tu gagnes ton argent france tu payes tes
impôts en france où on paie tous ses
impôts en france aussi a dû leur
tempérament ses idées s'il a démenti
il a démenti il a dit qu'il pèse ici
j'aimerais ses impôts en france la
partie des impôts en france il a payé en
france
la partie a au royaume-uni paix au
royaume uni enfin laissons lui quand
même le bénéfice du doute
alors il assume et innocent je suis
désolé degrés sur le nord et ça c'est
sûr je suis assez d'accord avec avec
kelly mais il dit il a dit exactement
dany boon depuis hier on m'interroge je
vous rassure immédiatement j'ai toujours
payé je paye je paierai toujours tout
l'impôt là où il met réclamée par tous
j'exerce mes activités professionnelles
et artistiques ça veut dire voilà quand
il est délocalisée il avait d'ailleurs
voilà donc comme il a délocalisé suisse
n'a rien d'une égale à celle que j'ai
regardé ce n'est pas illégal c'est
amoral
voilà et ça ça me joke c'est ça la vie
mais en tout cas c'est pas illégal 7 à
la morale c'est un moral d'autant que
c'est vrai que il est oui moi je suis le
patriote il s'est présenté comme le
parangon de celui qui paye est
formidablement ses impôts
quant à quelque chose qui est pas très
clair tu fermes ta gueule d'accord ça
c'est ça qui choque les gens aujourd'hui
mme info moi je dis si tu sais que t'es
pas clair tu te tais il a voulu parler
c'est bien fait pour lui et que
géraldine maillet nous donne des leçons
de journalistes quand est-ce que
meilleur marché
stratège comedia pas se tromper ça sert
à rien s'est plaint leur dossier à l'ema
et de dany boon qui vit entre armand jeu
mais je fais mes impôts ou me les
réclament
ça veut pas dire qu'il est payé en
france dans sa réponse mais ça veut dire
ce que ça veut dire voilà qui paye ses
impôts cantonaux police
oui mais il n'a pas il ya rien d'illégal
ans qu'il entraînait alors danser non
quatre vidéos en fait mediapart évoque
des éléments qui révèlent une attitude
étrange pour un homme qui se dit
patriote fiscale c'est ce que vous dites
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont compté avec
call mediapart erreur qu'il a fait c'est
qu'il est devant vazquez on voit bien à
la faveur de cette anecdote que dany
boon est très soucieux un titre
personnel et qu'ils s'impliquent là
dedans parce que sa fortune n'est pas de
lien avec un paradis fiscal seulement
voilà nous on a reçu un certain nombre
de documents par exemple là bas c'est
une structure qui est en fait un
investissement de dany boon aux îles
caïmans il a investi 7 190 mille livres
anglaises dans des hedge-funds toujours
à l'egypte est mort calmer pour un autre
compte en banque
là on est en septembre 2004 aux 1,1
million de dollars alors monsieur oui
j'ai eu une faute plus à la moralité
très sélectif quand cdh avait des idées
qui part au portugal pour payer moins
d'impôts là tu trouves ça normal
et quand c'est denis blum que tu aimes
pas visiblement il ya du peuple qui
devrait dans ce sens et là ça ne choque
donc tu es vraiment c'est quand tu veux
quoi alors avec gilles mais absolument
pas j'ai jamais dit que c'était bien ce
que j'ai la finaliser son sein gauche
qui le faisait chaque fois que les gens
utilisent même l'optimisation pour
quitter la france comme raymond disait
quand ils vivent de ce qu'on achète en
france leurs oeuvres sont en france
achetés par les français je trouve que
ça nommé va pas les filles ne devrait
pas faire ça et films sur ses excès les
galets ya désormais tous ses films dans
le monde entier c'est normal qu'ils
payent des impôts si elle bat mais vous
et a vendu des films du monde en titre
était ainsi à pas le public français qui
m'a voir les ch'tis nenê jallet boon il
existe
non mais des journalistes se sont même
rendus dans sa résidence en france où
ils font la rencontre de son gardien
regarder ces fous ils ont fait la chasse
aux sorcières est ce que ça vous choque
ça se regarde la lune des propriétés de
l'acteur se trouve dans le loiret comme
il est en tournage en ce moment en
région parisienne peut-être au râteau
une chance de le croiser bonjour des
journalistes on voulait poser qu'à un
peu quelques questions savoir s'il était
dans le coin savoir s'ils passent
beaucoup de temps ici mon pagne plus
rarement qu'avant on peut être un mois
dans la nuit en fait il est censé vivre
à l'étranger enfin il ya l'étranger ou
nés à l'étranger
il a beaucoup voyagé mais comme il s'est
construit un personnage de patriotes
fiscale très fort c'est qu'il sait alors
je voyais le souhait de gilles de gagner
beaucoup d'argent je vais te coller au
cul lui aura déjà tout ça tout ça tout
ce que devient des finances de gilles
faut virer ces retours
oui il a investi dans des fonds
spéculatifs
quand que trouvent aux îles caïmans et
la bave et la plupart des gens qui
gagnent beaucoup d'argent
le fond mais quant aux impôts il les
paye de toute façon normalement il pèse
50 % d'impôts et il a trois résidences
que ce soit à londres à bruxelles et los
angeles
c'est un peu le mec faut régler tombez
pas dans les pays où il va mais oui
c'est plus c'est plus avantageux mais
c'est tout voilà sur l'âme il n'y a rien
d'illégal 50% il paye nous ici c'est 65
ces voix là aussi c'est légal il faut
pas parler d'évasion fiscale il faut
parler d'optimisation et toute personne
qui a un avocat fiscaliste ou un
gestionnaire de patrimoine c'est qu'on
peut placer dans des dents des fonds et
ça n'a rien justement vous parlez d'un
avocat il ya un dernier explique je
voulais montrer où l'on découvre les
conseils donnés par ses avocats pour
échapper à l'impôt en france et une
enquête de mediapart je sais c'est que
géraldine là vous êtes énervé par ces
images
oui je trouve que c'est la traque c'est
la cache investigations c'est la télé
enfin procureur enfin regarder déteste
ça
tu as vu ses avocats lui disent qu'il
faut faire attention
en fait il faut qu'ils passent plus de
temps au royaume uni qu'en france oui
c'est ça du coup ils lui disent de tenir
deux calendriers 1 pour calculer le
nombre de jours passés au royaume uni
pile à minuit et l'autre pour calculer
le nombre de jours passés en france là
où il peut y avoir un débat s'il faut
comprendre c'est que quand vous voulez
dans un autre pays pour être fiscalisés
oui il faut passer plus de la moitié des
jours c'est à dire la moitié de 365
jours s'il est souvent il ya des gens
bayer des spécialistes là bas qui vont
voir votre courrier qui relève pour voir
visiblement ce que ce que relève
mediapart c'est que que ce soit en
angleterre ou en belgique
il annonce un nombre de jours passés là
bas qui ne serait en réalité pas
vraiment passée la phase actuelle c'est
pas des gages m'excuse mais on marche
sur la tête quand on voit les
préoccupations des français en ce moment
entendre que monsieur dany boon fait des
petits montages pour ne pas payer les
100% 65% d'impôt qui doit payer en
france non mais les gars on marche sur
la tête et que vous disiez que c'est
normal et que tous les gens ont des
comptes offshore ou je sais pas quoi
google a par exemple tous les footeux
des cooptés musée ton argent - chaînon
moi je suis bête chemin de la moitié
appartiennent à écouter tous pareils ce
tournoi mais surtout à sion certes les
gens en france ça m'insupporte parce que
toujours des grandes gueules pour dire
quand je reçois ma mamma feuille d'impôt
d'un grand sourire parce que je
participe aux on est tous pareils que
dans sa forme d'un faux nom mais vous
l'aurez prochaine ne sauverait pas
raymond kopa c'est ce que tout est dit
la vérité ici est-ce que vous pensez que
ça peut en porter préjudice à dany boon
oui oui non mais alors moi je dis
pourquoi lui tout seul y a pas que lui
les tournois partout dans le monde j'en
veux pas ils sont pas en france mais les
les footballeurs ils sont en france
ils jouent au football ce week-end en
france ils payent leurs impôts même
s'ils font des petits montages qu'on dit
c'est que le mot eshop quand vous dites
échapper à l'impôt français créé
entendait entendait le truand et entend
dénoncer un système d mais bien sûr
échapper à l'impôt français nous les
coups on peut pas échapper on est là on
est chez nous on travaille toute l'année
on est taxé techno a préféré des
français
il vit en suisse
oui j'étais tout seul sur ce cd jeune
jeanne et serge jeannet serre et
pourquoi maintenant ils cartonnent au
théâtre antoine en ce moment et c'est
pourquoi maintenant
et pourquoi lui c'est la question qu'on
peut se casser les cintres antoine c'est
les français qui vont devoir est à 30
watts et son téléport à belle île
arrêter avec ce côté sistema nation
hyper démago qui est on doit tout au
public de kubrick nous avons un public
doit servir à tout avec la caisse alors
là c'est déjà d'accord avec sais pas ce
que je dis je le dis je vais l'avoir
préparé des fournées magot mais mine de
rien moi mon succès je le dois au public
oui bien sûr qu'à un seul patron si les
téléspectateurs seront publiées je vous
dis la vérité et les patrons de chaînes
je les aime beaucoup
ben mais les patrons de chaînes je vous
le dis ainsi demain y'a pas publique
tu peux être leur meilleur copain ils en
ont rien à [ __ ] mon talent dehors donc
notre seul grand patriote et d'autres
solvay patron dans les métiers du
spectacle c'est public car ils sont
seuls patrons c'est le public désolé le
seul patron c'est les téléspectateurs
pour nous donc faut arrêter cette
station terminale es ce que vous avez
par exemple un avocat fiscaliste vous
alors
[Applaudissements]
je sentais alors tout à fait apte à
ramener pas foulé je voudrais alors mal
mais je ne sais quoi j'aime bien le jury
c'est très bien mais non mais non non
non non je vous le jure
mais je gg aucun compte à l'étranger et
vous pensez-vous monsieur ahmed
apparaissent comme je n'ai aucun compte
à l'étranger et je n'ai aucune boîte à
l'étranger et vous pensez vraiment
qu'ils aient ou les gens qui lui tapent
dessus s'il avait fait d'émettre des
montages à l'étranger ils n'auraient pas
déjà défoncée alors s'amuser un peu
alors franchement non oui ils n'ont pas
passé les gens aux chevaux au niveau au
niveau des impôts j'ai aucune
optimisation voilà je vous dis un joli
franchement c'est vrai voilà j'ai pas de
meilleur voilà pour faire des placements
comme ça mais il ya plein déplacements
qui sont officielles on invite à
défiscaliser en outaouais avec ses
terrasses de café tout le monde la
comptable autres comme ça s'il est
officialisé sur l'optimisation à
l'étranger qui choque la les jeux répond
directement à votre question est ce que
sa carrière est en danger oui non parce
que il s'est érigé en chantre comme je
le disais de je paye tous mes impôts en
france et son public et le très
impopulaire que le haut-lieu pauvres
animaux alors que naples 1 1 n'est pas
clos fo voilà il lui le pauvre comme il
cartonne à wii fit plus qui réserve ce
que les gens font des choses pas bien
que dans et bien sûr il m'a fallu faire
pour tout le monde mais bon voilà on y
est c'est vrai ben voilà le faux voilà
mais bon en tout cas médiapart c'est
vrai qu'ils mènent une guerre sans
théologique et pauline ans dont il veut
les monnaies restait idéologique et
politique les bons citoyens les mauvais
citoyens et voilà et carraro dany boon à
une mauvaise note et c'est un mauvais
citoyen pour médiapart ans